sie alle wollen auf und davon
christine schönbächler und ihr mann
hermann sie ziehen mit ihren kindern
regie und natascha nach kanada anja
kinski und claude wegmann wollen sich in
italien eine existenz aufbauen mit dabei
ist kino der trüffel und aniko und
orlando stamm geben ihrer jungen liebe
ein neues zuhause auf bali bauen sie
eine ferienanlage jennifer wettstein der
mann ali und söhnchen sven versprechen
sich in peru eine bessere zukunft in
lima sollen ihre träume wahr werden
[Musik]
als hermann schönbächler noch forstwart
in biel war merkte er allmählich dass es
ihm in der schweiz irgendwann zu eng
würde und weil er schon als kind bücher
über das leben in kanadas wäldern
gelesen hatte reifte in ihm der traum
der einst dazu leben wo ihm die bäume
bestimmt nie ausgehen
heute ist sein erster arbeitstag
ja der hof für die da sieht er damit
sehr stabil um in den wäldern von rost
will herrmann in den nächsten jahren
sein lebenswerk vollbringen eine
nachhaltige waldbewirtschaftung wie sie
die kanadier noch nicht gesehen haben
vor einer woche zogen die schönbächlers
in die kanadische wildnis und schon beim
ersten spaziergang entdeckten sie den
ersten elf in italien haben laut wegmann
und wann ihr kind mit den aufräum und
renovationsarbeiten ihres tage turismo
bekannte in bali wurden die letzten
dächer gedeckt erstmals gesuchten an iq
und orlando stammen die baustelle ihrer
bungalowanlage
in lima hingegen ärgerte sich der werner
haustechnik installateur ali beckstein
über einen rohrbruch seien neue wohnung
stand unter wasser
wenn der holzfäller hermann schönbächler
im wald auftaucht dann weiß auch der
kanadische baum was es geschlagen hat
es ist herrmanns erster arbeitstag und
sein vorgesetzter morgen farquhar stellt
ihn gleich zu beginn auf die probe
wir haben eine bliebe wäre das ein bruch
im blockhausbau und problem ist dass er
dass man genau wozu alle da hierüber der
größten semino machen
beim vc kanti wurzelwerk sagen wo ich
probiere man hier haut vergisst man dass
es anders geht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die aufgabe ist schwieriger als anfangs
angenommen aber ein hermann schönbächler
wächst an der herausforderung
[Musik]
die schweizer präzisionsarbeit verblüfft
selbst einen hart gesottenen kanadischen
baumfäller nun bekomme ich den job
wirklich beeindruckend dass du denn hier
auch noch als stehen lassen und die
kleine zehe dort auch echt beeindruckend
das ist was ich wollte
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
die habe kenntnis von netz genommen
diese tour war zuvor bei aber wir hoffen
dass jetzt der boom nach vorschrift
[Applaus]
sie stiegen gedanke mit david kommen
[Musik]
in mittelitalien sind bereits die
vorboten des frühlings zu erkennen
die temperaturen sind angenehm in der
region marke hier lebt claude wegmann
seit ein paar wochen auf einem
traumhaften flecken erde
doch sein landgut liegt seit jahren in
einem wahren dornröschenschlaf
der beamte muss bietet über 20 jahre und
hat teile von leid ich glaube christa
und rom bevor der telecom italia nach
und telefonberatung aus der baum wächst
ist nicht so versicherers fdp von links
und der wirklich taugt also eigentlich
ist aber nicht nur äußerst telefon
campus und das vorhaben die noch einer
das laufwerk ist lang und ich hätte
irgendwo 50 meter größe von der masse
sondern mit telefonieren die klitoris
chlodwig man scheut die arbeit nicht und
das ist gut so denn wohin er und seine
partnerin anja kinski und deren
schwester nina auch schauen gibt es jede
menge zu tun
das könnte doch regnen sehen sie hier
sie geben sich zwei jahre zeit um das
agriturismo aufzubauen
dann wollen sie hier selbstversorger
sein und gäste beherbergen
vor einem halben jahr haben die drei das
anwesen gekauft
doch oft arbeitet claude der ehemalige
werber allein anja die betriebsökonomie
arbeitet noch immer in der schweiz fährt
aber so oft wie möglich nach italien und
nina anja schwester die am projekt
beteiligt ist reist regelmäßig aus
kalifornien an claude und die zwei
frauen meist gehe das sehr gut
das war so ziemlich das zum teil
und ich meine meinung und zu thailand
und muss so dass aufeinander rücksicht
als mann oder frau ist ein einziges
gesetz gemerkt hat es auch frau sein die
eigene kleider schuhe zum beispiel mit
palms netz wurde die bank habe dann aber
kam's hin oder her
die zwei deutschen frauen mit eu pass
haben in italien den leichteren stand
als claude der schweizer woche bis dann
über rom ist und besten dorf politischen
hugo loetscher dauerwohnen dann ist dann
offiziell habe die politik arbeiteten
zerstört
die pure vor bestimme wer diese zahl
gestiegen
damit kommen
[Musik]
über den dächern von lima baut ali
wettstein fleißig an seinem neuen
zuhause
jede minute hat er die letzten drei
monate an der fertigstellung der wohnung
gearbeitet wenn er nicht gerade im
familieneigenen restaurant zu tun hatte
alle wohnt er zusammen mit seiner
peruanischen frau jenny und zu uns wend
gleich darunter in erdgeschoss liegt die
wohnung von alice schwiegermutter sarah
[Musik]
zusammen mit dennis gross mutter lilia
schauen sie svens bilder an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja ich bin mit der hand in hand es zieht
dann aber dem großen raum natürlich
jetzt mit dem gelernten haustechnik
installateur fallen die montagearbeiten
in der eigenen küche leicht
[Musik]
die postauto in der küche kann schon
bald gekocht werden
bisher sind jenny und ali mehr als ihnen
lieb ist auf jennys mutter sarah
angewiesen denn sarah hat nicht nur in
der pasta fabrik und im restaurant das
sagen die frau mama ist auch hier im
haus der boss
und jetzt müssen erfolge wie
funktioniert das aber die global skates
der langsam voll daneben klagte sie mir
natürlich doppelt wenn du es nicht gut
und das ist nicht gut
sie spiegeln
mit data group kommen
[Musik]
wenn sich an iq und orlando stamm in der
morgensonne paris auf den weg zur arbeit
machen dann tun sie dies als bauherren
die jeden tag zu sehen können wie ihr
kleines ferienparadies entsteht
die vorahnung des vermessungsingenieur
es aus der schweiz bestätigt sich
schnell an diesem tag im mai auf der
baustelle geht mal wieder gar nichts
die arbeiter sind zu hause und bereiten
sich auf die höchsten feiertage im jahr
vor
anni und orlando sind seit vier jahren
ein paar
seit beginn ihrer beziehung träumten sie
von einer gemeinsamen zukunft fern der
heimat wirklichkeit immer noch obwohl
ich das grund und das sehr gut
ich gehe nicht darum ob ich da gut was
machen eigentlich also ich einen daumen
als zwischen ihnen aber es war mir
darauf deren baustellen sind und die
sich schön ist einfach gut
aber die stimme für die nötige gefahr
bkb ist ganz ruhig stellen
das ist kino das ist natürlich da es
durch die exklusive und durch
genauso wie man es zeichnet hängt die
nach einer form gemacht und händler mehr
inländische sieger wird und hätte das
noch größer und jetzt kontrolliert
raster sich nachher und kontor ruf und
wird noch hoch poliert kannte noch
gebrochen und den nachgesät das ganze
ist los und was nur lästig ist einfach
da vorne dran betont besuchern oder
sondern haben dass das das glasdach
nochmals gesehen dass also kabel sind
ist abschloss ich das ziel ja kloster
alles perfekt aber das ist ja die
hiobsbotschaft der mann soll hängt das
mit al qaida offen
er hat die sprachlich von stress für
bio- oder und ich 56 mitleid ich möchte
für bandic machen und den hätte strom
oder und das bringen
da drehen jetzt nicht an das heißt sie
wenn sie wollen einfach nicht im moment
nimmt man einfach war denn wie hunderte
andere wartet da und langsam märz den
jobeinstieg mit vier wochen im
steuerrecht und dennoch mehr strom haben
wird pool der laufenden strom kein
wasser können wir unsere pumpen in den
wasserturm monate lang kein mensch in
den nächsten 14 tage der wirklichkeit
fuß an akku und denn auch am generator
kaufen
in bali warten orlando stamm und annika
auf strom
in italien hingegen kämpfen claude
wegmann und anja kind geht mit einem
motor
orangen denkt okay geben
anja und claude haben in ihren berufen
bisher vor allem kopf arbeit geleistet
jetzt geht es um handfeste probleme
abgesoffen
wie immer so was wie gesagt ich soll das
halten und aufgeben und aber nicht dass
ich auf 1 drücken soll
[Applaus]
[Musik]
voreingestellt
wer hat den vorhin getragen auch anjas
mutter ute ist in san martino zu besuch
und amüsiert sich köstlich
[Musik]
iris bachmann
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
endlich steht der arbeit nichts mehr im
weg
oder besser gesagt fast nichts mehr
[Musik]
da pro nicht austauschen müssten
maschinen kaputt na ja gesagt so viel
drinnen hier war verhältnis
sie stiegen die gewinne mit der fall gut
kommen
[Musik]
es ist frühling geworden auch im rauen
nordwesten kanadas christine und hermann
wollen mit den kindern das tun wovon sie
seit jahren träumen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einmal war
[Musik]
die turbine fans offen
die bootsfahrt auf dem kelm riva ist
vorläufig beendet das blut steckt auf
einer sandbank fest
nichts geht mehr niemand ahnt in diesem
augenblick dass sie vom nahen ufer her
neugierig beobachtet werden
und der motor springt nicht an
inzwischen feiert ganz bali gall ungarn
und komiker es ist der jahrestag der
schöpfung
[Musik]
ich sehe kritik auch was da drauf
die einheimischen sind in ihren
schönsten traditionellen kleidern
unterwegs zu opfer feiern in
hinduistischen tempeln
[Musik]
ruhig
das gute siegt interview kreiert und der
scheiße
richtig happy day lassen
[Musik]
und das sind
ferrari unterwegs
das auch anni und orlando zu den göttern
unterwegs sind hat einen guten grund sie
wollen einen tempel besuchen um die
götter um den dringend benötigten strom
zu bitten ihn war etwas schwierig dieses
gewand anzuziehen ja dass du auch gehen
kann
vor allem die vielen treppenstufen hoch
wie viele sind es 1000
etwa 1700 stufen seien priester als sich
hollande und anita den göttern gegeben
erinnert nichts mehr an ihr früheres
leben als vermessungsingenieur und
hauswirtschaftslehrerin das ist schön
dass man jetzt ist also mehr studieren
natürlich jetzt darum das projekt und
was man da nicht träumen schon vom tisch
gewesen dass nach ablauf nicht
funktioniert hat
und der strom geht der strom geht
vielleicht auch nach der wahl also in
die welt
das ich werde sicher ein problem
darstellt dass es so ist
schließlich schwitzen und zwar sehr
träge glaubt das ist dass das besser als
der letzte schnee in die lieferung es
ist feucht in diesen tagen und über 35
grad heiß und noch fehlen weit mehr als
1000 stufen bis ins ziel
wichtig ist ja oft links rechts wie von
links heinrich die insel der götter hier
bestimmen opfergaben rituale und
zeremonien den alltag
niemand würde in bali daran zweifeln
dass es die götter sein werden die
orlando und anif irgendwann den strom
bringen
und das nachdem sie die anschlüsse und
leitungen längst bezahlt haben
er hat ihre einzige niederlassung in
gebiete weg von einer hand das ist ja
der zeremonie die sind jetzt wahnsinnig
schön das läuft sehr ruhig ab und
schrieben wir hatten drei familien nach
der anderen oder kunst
[Musik]
in peru gönnt sich ali wettstein derweil
ein freies wochenende
marisa bock
afrika lebt
werden soll ich noch
was zu machen
jenny ist mit dem zweijährigen sven dem
zweiten auto unterwegs
während ali in den straßen von lima
heimischen klängen lauscht hört seine
frau im radio dass eine tsunami warnung
ausgegeben wird ein bisschen komisch sie
versprechen auch nicht gut und hat viel
zu tun
am strand gehen wieder aufbauen
janis familie besitzt seit ein paar
jahren dieses strandhaus am meer
heute ist jenny verunsichert denn das
meer scheint tatsächlich verrückt zu
spielen
ebbe und flut wechseln im minuten takt
erinnerungen an ihre ferien vor fünf
jahren in thailand tauchen auf als ali
und jenny den tsunami aus nächster nähe
miterlebte und nur knapp überlebten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
niemand mochte das leben
[Musik]
in kanada lauert fast zur gleichen zeit
eine ganz andere gefahr ein schwarzbär
nähert sich der familie schönbächler und
der motor des bootes springt noch immer
nicht an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum heißt der umstieg vom kino mit
wohnort post das ist
[Musik]
fragen wir sind schon besser situationen
nach oben
familie unterwegs mit zweifeln praxis
schon anders aber er hat nur
verantwortungsbewusst sie zum nachrüsten
[Musik]
es ist der erste tag nach dem tempel
besucht orlandos sohn andrin ist mit
seiner freundin für ein paar tage zu
besuch in bali andrin will sehen wie
papas neues leben ausschaut
geplant wäre das andrin als gelernter
elektriker ein paar geräte in der
ferienanlage seines vaters installiert
und dass mir selten optimal belichten
oder die hand dass das das ist einfach
ganz klar nickt er irgendwo alarm von
oben haben um fertigen gibt das war
schade denn audi und den nehmen wir das
eben die enorme das modell das beste
bringen und das erfordert denn da
strahlen zwar giftig also an drin
erfährt dass es einen monat vor der
eröffnung noch manche probleme gibt
rechten um total im recht als als andere
benz vans wenn sie bisher stellen denn
nicht sofort den ort aber wenn es andere
machen
ich erwarte auf damals sieht es in der
puren aus aber gaerte die lüftung und
sie probieren natürlich maximus auch
ohne dass ich verständlich doch die
ärgerlichste nachricht hat orlando bis
jetzt auf gespart hätte dass ich das ist
ja alles tasche alles gut und recht
nicht schlecht aber da aber da vor der
respektiven vor der oder ohne gnade gott
die hohen airline immer wichtig
das glaubt ihm fahrender dabei himmel
strom.de brandhoveweg tore und die hält
das ebm halbe jahr fertig braucht viel
weniger wo dort dürfen unglaube unglaube
stadt als ganzes risse und am schluss
weil wir machen uns nach einer deftigen
kann ihn da nur etwas die große liebe zu
seiner an
[Musik]
in italien bekommen claude anja und nina
besuch
die drei sind gewillt den tatsachen ins
auge zu sehen und haben deshalb baut ruf
ist eingeladen
diese sollen sich ihre liegenschaft bei
frühlings licht ansehen und die
gebäudesubstanz einschätzen denn je
länger je mehr befürchten die
auswanderer dass die renovationsarbeiten
weit aufwendiger werden als bisher
angenommen und die mauer sozusagen die
sind gut aber dass darin kann man alles
rausreißen
ja das dach es gefährlich ist gefährlich
punkt
ein eimer wasser und in zwei wochen ja
ein zwei wochen ist alles fertig das
hier haben wir erst gesehen als wir
alles raus geschafft hatten
[Applaus]
das haus ist schön aber es ist in
mittelmäßigen zustand nicht so sehr was
den äußeren teil betrifft denn die
mauern sind stark aber im inneren ist
eigentlich nichts geblieben
ich denke das war ein neustart
das war keine wohnung da haben sie
früher das heu für die tiere drin gehabt
[Musik]
wer vor einem berg von arbeit steht
sollte sich stärken damit die kraft auch
wirklich reicht denn in san martino in
der provinz la marke sind die berge in
diesen tagen definitiv höher geworden
als gedacht zustand des hauses ist mehr
oder weniger so wie wir eigentlich auch
dachten vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
noch also auch innen drin in ordnung da
hatten wir uns erhofft dass ein bisschen
mehr noch in ordnung ist aber die mauern
sagt der außenseiter okay das
das ist eigentlich ganz positiv und ja
und die dinge von dem wir auch wussten
dass man sich schnell machen kann das
was hat er eigentlich bestätigt und so
müssen wir jetzt eben weitermachen
nun ist allen bewusst dass der traum vom
aktuell noch viel zeit geld und arbeit
brauchen wird das user rhume werde mehr
versuche ich jetzt machen also ab jetzt
auch so einfach zu machen sind natürlich
traurig sind aber schlussendlich mehr
handwerklich scheint dieser will aber
ein günstiges italienische arbeiter aus
stelle ist noch grün steht bei mir
selber machen wo man nicht sagen können
wenn wir dafür brauchen strom oder dass
man nicht die letzte portal gemacht hat
einfach weiterführen
[Musik]
in peru ist die stimmung ausgelassen die
tsunami warnung hat sich zum glück nicht
bestätigt jenny alliance wenn können
jetzt doch noch ein paar stunden am
strand verbringen
[Musik]
das packt
auch lina m linie geht es gut da
entwickelt sich gut
das ist halt so viel mehr kann man am
strand hocke toll doch die familien
idylle ist schon bald vorbei ali muss
abschied nehmen er kehrt in die schweiz
zurück um die haushaltskasse
aufzubessern claude muss italien noch
härter anpacken
[Musik]
während anja und nina sich den zarten
aufgaben widmen
in bali wein anni und rolando hier
ferien resort ein und in kanada bereitet
sich hermann auf den sommer vor der bart
muss weg dies und mehr
nächste woche bei auf und davon
[Musik]